Four years ago, I could barely write a
tweet. Today, I'm one of the most
respected copywriters in the creator
economy with over 5,000 email
subscribers and 10,000 followers online
who read and buy my stuff. And in this
video, I'm going to show you exactly
what I did to get so good so fast and
blow past 99% of copywriters. [music]
Here's what most copywriters do. They
read a couple copywriting books, they
write some emails, and then they start
chasing clients. Then what happens is
they spend about 80% of their time on
outreach. Then when they finally land a
client, they now shift 80% of their time
to managing that client and trying to
get another client, which leads to very
little time [music] actually writing.
And if you haven't guessed it, ding ding
ding. The number one way to get really
good at copywriting is not by chasing
clients or stroking AI. It's writing.
Which is exactly why what I'm about to
tell you actually works. [music] Instead
of chasing clients, be your own client.
Build your own audience online, grow
your [music] own email list, and sell
your own stuff. This is what I've done
for the past 3 years. And that's exactly
how I've grown my social following to
over 10,000 followers, over 5,000 email
subscribers, and multi6 figures sold of
my own products. Not to mention, I have
some of the biggest names in the
copywriting and creator industry who
read my stuff. people like Daniel
Thrasell, Brian Curts, Kieran Drew,
Eddie Quan, Art of Purpose, and a whole
bunch of other creators who tell me how
much they love my stuff. And it all
stemmed from outriding everybody else
who was chasing clients. Here's the
math. If you're side hustling [music]
a client-based business, let's say you
spend about 10 hours per week on that
business, [music] about eight of your
hours will be spent in outreach, and
about two of your hours will be spent
writing for those clients. In one year,
you'll have spent 104 hours writing.
That's not bad. But if you do creator
work instead of client work, look at
these numbers. Spend the same amount of
time, 10 hours per [music] week. You'll
spend about 8 hours of that 10 writing
tweets, emails, blogs, [music] articles,
YouTube scripts, threads, all the stuff.
And then you'll spend about 2 hours per
week managing the brand, replying to
comments, setting up the automations,
posting the content. In one year, you'll
have written 416 [music] hours. This is
4x the amount the person chasing clients
is writing, which again is 99% of
copywriters. But it's not just the time
spent. There are two other reasons why
doing creator work instead of client
work will make you infinitely better
than all the other copywriters. Reason
number two is you get instant feedback.
You send an email and you see if it made
sales. You post a tweet and you see the
engagement metrics immediately. Did it
do well? Likes, comments, things like
that. You post a YouTube video, did it
go viral? Did it get less views?
Everything in the creator economy has
data that tells you if it's good or bad.
With client work, you'll write copy,
you'll wait a week, they'll give you
some revisions, you'll rewrite it,
you'll finally publish it, and then
you'll get some stats. That is learning
in slow motion. When you are a creator,
you learn in real time. And the third
and final reason why you will blow past
99% of copywriters when you do creator
work is that you are doing
permissionless writing. [music] You can
test any headline, try any story
structure, tweak any offer, write in any
voice. Whereas when you're writing for
clients, they give you feedback like
make it more professional or that
doesn't sound like our brand voice or
that's too bold, we can't say that. Or
we talk to legal, we can't say those
things either. [music] clients
constantly compromise your copy where in
the creator economy you can be [music]
free. So here's what I want you to do.
I'm going to give you a road map, okay?
I want you to go to Subsac and start an
account. This is not a plug. I'm not
affiliated. It's just a really good
platform to write on. And for the next 6
months, I want you to do this every day.
I want you to write three short posts.
Think like tweets. And I want you to
write one article that becomes an email.
[music] It will take you about 60 to 90
minutes a day. and it'll end up about a
thousand words a day. This is the same
amount of time that you would [music]
spend building a client-based business
anyway. And in one year, you'll have
practiced 1,000 headlines, 365 subject
lines, 365 offers, and 365
stories. Well, as your client-faced
copywriter friends, they probably write
50 to 100 emails, one to two a week, for
their clients, and that's about it. It's
literally like going to the gym every
day while your friends go twice a week.
And over six months, this is probably
how it's going to look like for you.
Month one, you're going to be figuring
it out. You're going to bumble around.
What's my niche? What should I be
saying? It it is you discovering your
vibe. Month two, you're going to start
seeing what works, what post took off,
what post didn't take off. Month three,
you're going to gain a little bit of
confidence because at that point, you'll
have had some posts that did really
well, some articles that got some reads.
Month four, you're really finding your
voice. You're starting to understand how
you like to write, what you don't like
to write, and in fact, you'll start
writing a lot faster. Month five, you're
going to start doubling down on what
works. You're going to understand your
niche better. You're going to understand
what posts do really well. You're going
to understand what goes viral. And by
month six, you'll have done more work in
6 months than other copywriters have
done in 2 years, which is typically when
a slew of people quit, which now puts
you in the upper echelon, that top 5%.
Not to mention, you are building your
own online audience and your own assets
that can sell while you sleep while the
rest of the copywriters are out there
chasing clients, trading time for money,
which is another double-edged sword
because your audience and assets make
you more attractive to clients if you
wanted clients [music] anyway. And then
because you're on Substack, you can just
turn your newsletter into a paid
newsletter and start monetizing that
way. Assets, newsletter, courses,
whatever. And all this takes is four
things. [music] You need a niche, a
substack, an hour a day, and a,000
[music] words that you write. That's
exactly how to become a top 1%
copywriter in 6 to 12 months. I know
this works and it's exactly why I
created a club called the Copy Creator
Club. And it's a community on school
where I help copywriters fire their
clients in their 9to-5 and build their
own list, sell their own stuff. But Copy
Creator Club is an exclusive offer only
to people who are on my email list. So
if you want the support of copywriters
doing the exact same thing that I just
told you in this video, then join my
email list down below. In fact, I have
some free [music] gifts when you join
and you'll get the exclusive opportunity
to join the copy creator club. I highly
recommend clicking down the link below.
Again, I got some free gifts when you
join a 63 cash cow copywriting secrets
guide just for you. But if you don't
want to join, you don't care about Copyc
Creator Club, doesn't matter. That's
fine. No big deal. What you need to do
right now is go to Substack, create a
profile, start writing today. Go build
your business. Which, by the way, slight
plug again, I do have a 1-hour master
class on how to build and launch your
Substack in 1 hour exclusively in Copy
Creator Club. [music] Last plug. But
either way, you don't need me. You can
go start writing today. I hope you found
this video helpful. If so, please like
and subscribe. It tells me that you want
me to put out more free content like
this and help you in your copywriter and
creator journey. Drop a comment below.
Tell me what you want to see next and
I'll make the video for you. Thanks
again for watching. I'll see you on the
next time. Oh boy, I cooked. Oh Jesus, I
was sitting there spitting fire. I just
heard a story that Dan Kennedy taught a
seminar with a bunch of his clients and
he wore a hat [music] that said clients
suck.
What a G, man. Dan Kennedy, he's the OG.
I haven't verified if that's a true
story, but one day I'm going to write an
email about it cuz that's just so funny.
And the ironic thing is I think uh
Doberman Dan wrote a blog article about
that event and [music] he was teaching
all these things about how clients are
the worst. Dan Kennedy was teaching all
these things about how clients are the
worst [music] and there were still a
bunch of clients in the auditorium
listening. They were like, "Dan, we'll
pay you 30 grand to write for us." It's
so funny. See, that's what happens when
you build your own brand, your own
authority. is clients will just beg for
you to write for them. Even if you're
like, "You're the worst. You suck." And
you wear a hat that's like, "You suck."
That's so funny. Oh man, I love it.
Build your own stuff. Okay? Go write
your own crap